why do you trust human leadership  I just think men are better at certain  things in general like I'll give you an  example I'm one of 10. so it's a pretty  big sample size just like kids and most  of my brothers are engineers and like  most of um me and my sisters  um actually most of my sisters don't  have jobs yet but they won't be  Engineers like I just know them but  I don't know I just think like with  money like especially with money I think  just men tend to make better decisions  and the data supports it so like women  make 70 to 80 percent of consumer buying  decisions and like we have more debt  even though we make less money and so to  me that's just as like women as a whole  we make impulsive emotional decisions in  general and there's some women that can  kind of turn that off but I don't think  it's like natural to us and that's why  like they most ad campaigns are targeted  towards women